as if its own internal conflict and
poverty weren't enough Chad has for some
years become a place of Refuge to many
fleeing Wars in neighboring countries
tribal clashes in Cameroon drove Fatima
Hassan to this refugee camp in Western
Chad
we can't go back to our village we have
seen many corpses there some of the
people were killed in front of our eyes
we can't go back
she isn't alone there are about one
hundred thousand cameroonian refugees in
Chad nearly 10 000 of them are here in
the kalabari camp
but Chad hosts dozens of similar camps
with refugees from the Central African
Republic Darfur Nigeria and elsewhere
and this is a part of a wider phenomenon
across Central and Eastern Africa
ongoing conflicts have created millions
of refugees and displaced people in
Somalia Ethiopia Kenya Wanda Burundi
Eritrea Sudan and the Democratic
Republic of Congo last year United
Nations estimated the number of refugees
and forcibly displaced persons in Africa
had reached 36 million
the reason behind these refugees and
displaced people is well known and it is
mainly the lack of peace and coexistence
for Africa to go forward and to achieve
progress we must establish peace here at
the kalabari aid agencies are trying to
help in different ways including small
agricultural projects where refugees can
grow their own food the camps provide
temporary shelter but they are
struggling when it comes to other basic
requirements the refugees know they
don't have a long-term future in chat
for now they say they feel thankful for
the safety they are enjoying and can
only hope for peace to Prevail in their
countries so they can return home
Muhammad Al Jazeera